investors concerned about the escalating
trade war with China are hoping for some
calm on Wall Street today Dow Jones
Industrials plunged more than 600 points
yesterday their worst loss in more than
four months this followed China's
decision to raise tariffs on 60 billion
dollars in US goods after President
Trump increased tariffs on Chinese
products Ben Tracy is sorting it all out
for us at the White House where the
president seems ready for more conflict
Ben good morning good morning so the
president has already sent out several
tweets this morning about China in one
saying that the u.s. is in a better
position now than if he had reached a
trade deal meanwhile China is vowing to
fight this trade war to the finish well
let you know in about three or four
weeks whether or not it was successful
you never really know right but I have a
feeling it's going to be very successful
President Trump seems confident he's
winning the trade war his advice to
American companies worried about higher
prices due to tariffs stop buying
products from China open your division
or open up your product have it made in
this country as opposed to made in China
frustrated at a lack of progress the
president is now taking the first step
toward imposing tariffs on another
approximately 300 billion dollars worth
of Chinese goods
this would make items Americans
regularly buy 25 percent more expensive
with nearly 5,000 products impacted
you'll feel the effects whether you're
shopping at the supermarket or the
hardware store baby products like infant
formula pacifiers and clothing will get
more expensive and so will Apple
products like iPhones and iPads I would
say it's everything but the kitchen sink
but it turns out kitchen sinks are on
this list too American farmers already
reeling from the first round of tariffs
last year will likely be hit hardest a
farmers have been incredible no country
can get in the way of our farmers
President Trump says he plans to bail
out farmers who've lost business because
of the tariffs with about 15 billion
dollars of tariff revenue that's the tax
US companies are paying to import many
Chinese goods this despite the
president's repeated claim that the
Chinese not Americans are paying the
price for the trade war
no one's winning and clearly everybody
is potentially going to lose and
probably lose a lot more than they
realize
president Trump plans to meet with
Chinese President Xi Jingping at the g20
summit in Japan next month you may see
these two leaders try to work out some
sort of ceasefire face-to-face but so
far there has been no announcement of
any new trade talks leading up to that
meeting Gael all right Thank You Ben
reporting from Washington